WITH THE PRESIDENT'S POLICY ON
UKRAINE.
WE KNOW ALMOST NOTHING ABOUT
THIS PERSON.
WE SAY A MAN, IT COULD BE A
WOMAN.
CONTEXT IS IMPORTANT.
IS THIS PERSON A PARTISAN?
HOW MUCH ACCESS TO HE OR SHE
HAVE?
WHAT EXACTLY ARE HIS OR HER
MOTIVES?
IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW ALL OF
THAT AS WE ASSESS THE CURRENT
IMPEACHMENT.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES SITS ATA
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES SITS ATT
THE EPICENTER OF THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AND HE IS WITH US
TONIGHT FOR THINKING SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON, CONGRESSMAN.
WHY CAN'T WE KNOW MORE ABOUT
THIS PERSON BEING DESCRIBED AS
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A VERY GOOD
QUESTION, BECAUSE AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
OF THE INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IS
OBSTRUCTING OUR INVESTIGATION,
WHICH I THINK IS A CRIME.
IT IS NOT OKAY FOR ONLY ONE
PARTY TO KNOW ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
FURTHERMORE, THE DEMOCRATS ON
THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR STAFF
WHO SEEM TO KNOW THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THEY ALSO WON'T
TELL US.
HERE'S WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
THE POINT YOU MADE.
I KNOW THERE IS LOTS OF
SPECULATION OUT THERE ABOUT WHO
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER MAY BE.
I'M NOT A LOW LAWYER
, BUT UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE TO
HANG OUT WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYERS
HANG OUT WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYER,
HANG OUT WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYERA
HANG OUT WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYERD
HANG OUT WITH A BUNCH OF LAWYERI
SAY THAT HALFWAY JOKING, AND
ONLY HALFWAY JOKING.
BUT WHAT THE LAWYERS TELL ME IS
THAT THIS WOULD NOT BE
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT.
YOU CANNOT TAKE HEARSAY FROM A
SUPPOSE IT, SOMEBODY WHO WE'VE
NEVER MET, WE CAN'T JUST TAKE
THE WORD OF SOME LAWYER AND THE
IG AND THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS PERSON HAS TO HAVE A NAME,
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY EXIST FOR
THIS TO BE CONSIDERED REAL
EVIDENCE IN AN INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THE HYENAS ON
TELEVISION ARE JUMPING UP AND
DOWN, HOW DARE YOU WANT TO KNOW
THE IDENTITY OF THIS PERSON?
WHICH IS QUITE FRANKLY INSULTING
TO THOSE OF US WHO GIVE OUR
OPINIONS EVERYDAY OUT THERE.
YOU DO A COME EVERYONE KNOWS
YOUR NAME, WHERE YOU LIVE.
IF YOU HAVE AN OPINION, STAND UP
AND BE COUNTED FOR IT, THIS IS
AMERICAN.
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY ANSWER THE
QUESTION, HOW CAN WE ASSESS THE
CLAIMS THIS PERSON HAS MADE IF
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THIS PERSON IS
OR WHERE HE IS COMING FROM?
IF THIS PERSON IS IN FACT A HARD
PARTISAN, ISN'T THAT RELEVANT TO
THE CASE?
IT'S A SINCERE QUESTION.
>> YOU'VE ANSWERED YOUR OWN
QUESTION.
WE CANNOT.
WE CANNOT EVEN BEGIN.
THIS IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO SAY
THAT ADAM SCHIFF AND/OR HIS
STAFF, WHOEVER HAS MET WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THEY ARE FACT,
FOUNDATIONAL WITNESSES TO THIS
DISASTER.
>> Tucker: THEN WHY ARE WE
BEING BULLIED BY THESE PEOPLE?
WHY ARE WE IN THE NEWS MEDIA --
THE TRUTH IS, AS YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
A LOT OF US DO.
IN ALL THESE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
ARE BEING BULLIED, IN EFFECT, BY
ADAM SCHIFF.
BY THE POWER OF HIS AGGRESSION
AND THE BOLDNESS OF HIS CLAIMS.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT, YOU'RE
PUTTING A MAN'S LIFE IN DANGER!
REALLY?
WHY BE QUIET, YOU DEMAGOGUE?
WHY ARE WE ALLOWING OURSELVES TO
BE BULLIED BY THIS GUY,
SERIOUSLY?
>> LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT THE
HYPOCRISY OF THIS.
IT WAS ONLY A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
THERE WAS THE SUPPOSE IT
INFORMANT WHO WAS EXTRACTED OUT
OF RUSSIA AND YOU HAD ALL THE
MAJOR NEWSPAPERS SHOWING HIS
NAME, GOING TO HIS HOUSE, TAKING
PICTURES.
SO SOMETIMES, WHEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WANTS TO OUT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER, OR OUT IN
INFORMANT BECAUSE IT IS A
RUSSIAN WHO MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING
BAD TO DO WITH TRUMP, THEN THEY
DO IT.
BUT IF IT SOMEBODY WHO
CLEARLY -- LOOK, THEY'RE TELLING
US EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW.
AND THAT IS, HOWEVER THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS MUST BE AN
EXTREME PARTISAN WITH LOTS OF
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR STORY.
THAT IS WHY THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
IS NOT COMING FORWARD.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, AND I HATE THE
TERM BECAUSE IF THE PERSON WHO
IS BEING IDENTIFIED AS A
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER IS IN
FACT THAT PERSON, HE'S NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER AT ALL.
HE IS A GUY WHO DISAGREES WITH
TRUMP'S FOREIGN POLICY VIEWS.
THAT IS NOT A WHISTLE-BLOWER.
BUT DO YOU THINK THAT THE PERSON
BEING DESCRIBED IN SOME NEWS
STORIES AND ALL OVER TWITTER, IS
THAT THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
BECAUSE IF IT IS, THAT GUY IS A
SERIOUS PARTISAN.
>> LOOKED, REGARDLESS, THE
PERSON WHO IS BEING DESCRIBED,
WE HAVE NO WAY TO KNOW.
IF THE PERSON WHO IS BEING
DESCRIBED AND NOBODY WANTS TO
SAY THE NAME, THAT PERSON HAS
GOT TO COME TESTIFY WHETHER THEY
LIKE IT OR NOT.
THEY ARE GOING TO TESTIFY.
IF ADAM SCHIFF AND THE DEMOCRATS
IN THE HOUSE DON'T LET THAT
PERSON COME TESTIFY TO THE
HOUSE, I GUARANTEE YOU, IF THEY
IMPEACH, THAT PERSON WILL HAVE T
IMPEACH, THAT PERSON WILL HAVE O
IMPEACH, THAT PERSON WILL HAVE B
IMPEACH, THAT PERSON WILL HAVE E
CALLED.
I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
MITCH McCONNELL'S MOUTH BUT HE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD HAVE TO.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT NAMING HIM
BECAUSE I CAN'T GET ANYONE TO
CONFIRM THAT IT IS REALLY HIM
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE IT IS HIM.
BUT I WANT TO GET CONFIRMATION.
>> EXACTLY BUT IT GOES BACK TO
WHAT WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT.
RIGHT NOW THERE TRULY IS NO
WHISTLEBLOWER.
THERE IS ONLY A WHISTLEBLOWER ON
PAPER.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE RIGHT NOW,
NOT UNTIL BOTH PARTIES.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF THIS COUNTRY
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF THIS COUNTR
COUNTRY.
I'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, YOU HAVE TO
ALLOW THE WHISTLEBLOWER, WHOEVER
THAT MAY BE, TO COME TO BOTH
PARTIES AND IF YOU ARE NOT DOING
THAT, THERE IS NO --
>> Tucker: HIS LIFE IS IN
DANGER, SPARE ME.
TRY LIVING MY LIFE FOR A WEEK.
DEVIN THANK YOU.
THE RUSSIAN HOAX COLLAPSED
BECAUSE OF ITS OWN STUPIDITY BUT
AMAZINGLY IT IS STILL CLAIMING
VICTIMS.